Travis Kelce the Chiefs tight in what
did you make a Vance MacDonald's play
last night man Vance getting it going
I've always been a big fan of Vance yeah
we came out the same year in the draft
and got to know each other a little bit
at the at the combine and it was it was
um it was cool meeting them and seeing
I'm a hard worker the guy is I mean he's
a he's absolute of a dude he's a big big
guy when you when you get up in front of
him but he's uh and he can roll
obviously showed that yesterday you can
roll when he got the ball his hands but
you're allowed to stiff arm is the
defense allowed to do the same I believe
so I just don't think they're allowed to
grab the face mat and neither side of
the ball is allowed to grab the facemask
we're uh we're allowed to go ahead and
do that our youth are you making the
reference that the defense isn't allowed
to make physical plays anymore
yeah I am Travis yeah come on it's
embarrassing now Travis yeah getting a
little weird and everybody in the league
feels the exact same way about it there
have been a few calls
obviously the Clay Matthews sack that
was I was called back to the
interception that the Vikings threw a
couple of games ago that was obviously
the one that it's just like all right
enough to know like we got it we can't
keep going along with this because I
know it's changing out coming up
football games and nobody wants it once
this kind of ending to a football game
so well even the quarterbacks I mean I
know that we're protecting the
quarterbacks I know we should protect
the quarterbacks because people tune in
to see the quarterbacks but it at times
it doesn't feel like it's real football
it feels like there's 21 players who
play by one rule and then there's one
player a china doll that plays by a
different rule yeah a lot of
quarterbacks out there that have pride
and are tough guys there so they're
actually are tough quarterbacks out
there so they're kind of looking at this
rule like oh man this is making me look
like a you know like a softie er this is
this is making me look like I'm the bad
guy I don't even want any of this to
happen so it's just uh it's tough for
everybody right now and unfortunately we
got to get this thing figured out full
introduction here Travis Kelce the
Chiefs tied in joining us on behalf of
the
ooh Old Spice beard care collection
helping guys achieve these soft
nourished and sculpted beards of their
dreams had your brother on yesterday you
said the last time you guys got in a
fight
pickup basketball game you were probably
a sophomore in high school it came it
spread into the house I believe and your
dad was involved in this do you remember
such occasion oh yeah I think it was the
last time that we really got into it I
ended up in a body slam in both of them
and we ended up breaking some stuff in
the kitchen wait about turning into a
man I was a young boy that turned into a
man that day is that when you knew you
could play in the NFL no no but that
would definitely gain some some
confidence I was uh because I had never
really taken it to that extent of
fighting back that much I mean I my
brother was always bigger stronger than
me so that at that point in time I was
mad enough and the care of getting my
tail looked anymore was just out the
window I feared I was I was carefree in
that regard so it was just uh and what
happened to work I wasn't you know what
I was thankful for I was I was kind of
thankful that my dad got a little banged
up is when he hit the floor he started
screaming no my back so and then that
ended the fight right there so Jason
couldn't retaliate after that good dad's
hurt so it was just like oh nice I just
win that I'm not even worried about that
what was dinner like that night after
dad gets hurt I think it was it was
smooth it was okay
dad dad there's some ice on his back I
think we ended up getting some pizza
that night because he broke the stove it
was it was smooth all right could you
take your brother now um you know what I
wouldn't even want to try it no wouldn't
even want to try that is a that is a
beast that that I would not walk to
awake and it's it's something that I do
it just loved to stay away from yah no
blame you it always like it feels like
your brothers
little crazy I don't know if it's by
design or not oh yeah I kind of got the
free Hall Pass when I got to high school
because everybody knew that my brother
was crazy and he had a bit of a temper
flare and that ever a problem so
everybody knew not to mess with the
Kelsi boys just because they see Jason
flip out and nobody wants to be a part
of that when did you know mahomes was
the future for you guys I mean you we
love the to sit here and say as soon as
as soon as he got into the practices and
we started seeing him throw the ball all
over the place they're throwing these
no-look passes in scout team last year
and then when he finally got in the game
last year the last Denver game like
Manny she's shown it is the guy but I I
personally I didn't I wasn't fully on
board until that first game and I know
it might sound a little bad right don't
get me wrong I always go out there I
played my tail off for the guys he's a
great guy a hell of a teammate so I mean
I was always gonna go out there and give
him my best for the guy and I had
confidence that we could win with him
but I mean in terms of 13 touchdowns in
three games I didn't see that one coming
so it's just it was cool to see him go
out there in that first game with
confidence sling the ball around know
where he's going with the ball and just
just being able to be composed
throughout the entire game ups and downs
and everything I was looking at it and
really surprised and it hats off to the
guy I mean he's a real deal what's the
difference between his ball and Alex
Smith does it hurt your hand out there
no no nothing nothing in that regard you
say you can still put it on you and
you're not sitting here with your hands
stinging or anything like that he still
throws a catchable football the biggest
difference I would probably say is is
the deep ball obviously it says he
throws it a mile and a half but Alex
Alex usually likes to get his his D
throws up and down before 40 yards and
pad pads ready to sling that thing 70 at
any point again
he's just ready to show it show it off
so I think just just in your mind you
have to run like it there's no there's
no like looking for the ball and then
kind of kind of slowing down I know
sometimes when you know you're not
getting the ball after like 30 yards
I'll feel the ball tonight in the air
all right I can kind of slow down here
know what pad you got to keep running
because it could be coming any second
he's got a unique voice how's that boys
sound in the huddle or Lynas from unique
boy said we we got our home a lot as a
rookie but now that he's the guy we kind
of lightened up on it and it's only it's
only did you only take shots here and
there wait how did you make fun of his
voice you just you could just hear the
rasp enos in it a few of a few of his
huddle calls getting pretty it gets
pretty funny and everyone will break the
hull laughing it's just um it's hard to
it's hard to hear him at times when he's
when he's yelling it's like he's like
his voice is gone but he's mumbling and
then at the end of eight you can just
put all of what he just said together oh
that's right here we have a look on it
that's for sure
does it sound a little bit like this red
right 84 red right 84 he's got a little
bit Texas country's 20 to him too so
it's uh it can get pretty funny some of
the stuff he said hilarious yeah it
sounds like he's had whiskey the night
before and he's got that southern
southern draw to it it's like an NBA
coach when he gets to the playoffs his
voice is just shot and you know here he
is he's Travis Kelce he was named the
bearded Old Spice guy and you can check
out all the all the stuff at amazon.com
anything else that you would like to
mention with this a great promotion
I mean Old Spice gets down to the beard
nests with its new beard collection you
can grab it on amazon.com exclusively
available on amazon.com you can also
check out our new beard poem book The
Old Spice guys grooming guidance guide
for guys with beards and other poems'
believe it's just a dollar on the Amazon
as well yeah your brother read a couple
of poems yesterday he went wait way too
deep way too deeply oh my gosh yes and I
think that he was really serious about
it so I had to be careful in my critique
when I went he said what do you think
serious matter oh I know if I could draw
a beard I did then you know I would I
guess I would be able to relate but I
was trying to be nice cuz who knows if I
run into your brother I don't want to be
body-slammed
I don't want yeah yeah you always gotta
have that in the back ear in mind when
you have conversations with Jason you
just never know I mean he's a big bite
explain guy so I didn't know he played a
musical instrument Oh several several he
taught himself the guitar in college the
ukulele one weekend in Hawaii I kidding
I mean heck growing up I absolutely
hated it I appreciate it now because it
was cool it's cool for him to know all
these instruments by me he was just
playing the the saxophone was his first
instrument then he got into the flute
the clarinet and the most annoying one
was definitely definitely the the drums
he got into and it's not like a drum set
it's like the African drums like he's
banging on one drum trying to make it
sound good and it was just like what are
you doing dude over and over and over
hey good luck against the Broncos on
Monday night always great to visit with
you and hopefully talk to you during the
season again all right Travis Kelce
Chiefs tight in one of our favorites his
brother was fun that was first time I
think we had his brother on yesterday
he's the center for the Philadelphia
Eagles imagine that household get two
kids playing in the NFL at a very high
level all pros grew up in Cleveland you
put Daddy to the hardwood the younger
pizza yeah I couldn't imagine doing that
growing up like with my dad where you
know he
collateral damage yeah I got involved in
fights with my brothers but but it was
rare when him like it would spill in
from outside into the kitchen and all of
a sudden you know dad gets body slammed
oh I can say is there wouldn't have been
dinner if that happened there would not
have been dinner for more Dan Patrick
show to the audience channel 239 on
Direct TV or download the Dan Patrick
show ass
[Music]